if i were to walk up to you on the
street and say you please tell me what
no i didn't want to write that thick
please tell me what sine of pi over
4 is and obviously we're assuming we're
dealing in radians you either have that
memorized or you would draw the unit
circle right there
that's not the best looking unit circle
but you get the idea
you would go to pi over 4 radians
which is the same thing as 45 degrees
you draw that unit radius out and the
sine is defined as the y-coordinate
on the unit circle so you would just
want to know this value right here and
you would immediately see okay this is a
45 degrees let me draw the triangle a
little bit larger
the triangle looks like this this is 45
that's 45 degrees this is 90.
this is 90 and you can solve a 4545
90 triangle the hypotenuse is 1 this is
x this is x they're going to be the same
values this is a this is an isosceles
triangle right their base angles are the
same so you say look x squared plus x
squared is equal to 1 squared which is
just one two x squared is equal to one x
squared is equal to one half
x is equal to
the square root of one half which is one
over the square root of two
i can put that in rational form by
multiplying that by the square root of
two over two
tau over the square multiplying that by
the square root of two over two and i
get x is equal to the square root of two
over two
so the height here
is square root of two over two and if
you want to know this distance 2 it
would also be the same thing but we just
cared about the height because the sine
value the sine of this is just this
height right here the y coordinate and
we got that as the square root of 2
over 2. this is all review we learned
this in the in the in the in the um
in the unit circle video but what if
someone else let's say on another day i
come up to you and i say
you
please tell me
please tell me what the arc sine
arc sine of the square root of 2 over 2
is
what is the arc sine and you're stumped
you're like i know what the sine of an
angle is but this is some new some new
trigonometric function that sal has
devised and all you have to realize when
they have this word arc in front of it
this is also sometimes referred to as
the inverse sine this could have just as
easily been written as
what is the inverse sine of the square
root of two over two
all this is asking is
what angle would i have to take the sine
of
in order to get the value square root of
two over two this is also asking what
angle would i have to take the sine of
in order to get square root of 2 over 2.
i could rewrite either of these
statements i could rewrite either of
these statements as saying
square let me do it
i could rewrite either of these
statements as saying
sine
of what
is equal to the square root of two over
two
and this i think is a much easier
question for you to answer sine of what
is square root of two over two well i
just figured out that the sine of pi
over four is square root of two over two
so in this case you know i know that the
sine of pi over four is equal to square
root of two over two so my question mark
is equal to pi over 4
or i could have rewritten this as the
arc sine
sorry
of square root of 2 over 2 is equal to
pi
over 4.
now you might say so
just as a review i'm giving you a value
and i'm saying give me an angle that
gives me when i take the sine of that
angle that gives me that value
but you're like hey sal
look
let me go over here you're like look pi
over 2 worked 45 degrees worked but i
could just keep adding 360 degrees or i
could keep just adding 2 pi and all of
those would work because those would all
get me to that same point on the unit
circle
right and you'd be correct and so all of
those values you would think would be
valid answers for this
right because if you take the sign of
any of those angles you could just keep
adding 360 degrees
if you take the sine of any of them you
would get square root of 2 over 2. and
that's a problem you can't have a
function where if i take the function
you know where i can't have a function
f of x where it maps to multiple values
right where it maps to pi over 4 or it
maps to pi over 4
plus 2 pi or pi over 4
plus
plus 4 pi so in order for this to be a
valid function in order for the inverse
sine function to be valid i have to
restrict its range and the way that
we'll just restrict its range to the
most natural place
so let's restrict its range
and actually just as a as a side note
what's its domain restricted to so if
i'm taking the arc sine of something
so if i'm taking the arc
sine
of x and i'm saying that that is equal
to
theta what's the domain restricted to
what are the valid values of x
x could be equal to what
well if i take the sine of any angle i
can only get values between 1 and
negative 1 right
so x is going to be greater than or
equal to negative one and then less than
or equal to one that's the domain
now in order to make this a valid
function i have to restrict the range
the possible values have to restrict the
range and for arcsin the convention is
is to restrict it to the first and
fourth quadrants
to restrict the possible angles
to this area right here along the unit
circle so theta
is restricted to being less than or
equal to pi over 2
and then greater than or equal to
greater than or equal to minus
pi over 2. so given that we now
understand what arc sine is let's do
let's do another problem let me clear
out some space here
let me do another arc sign so let's say
i were to ask you what the arc sine
the arc sine
of
minus square root of 3 over 2 is minus
square root of 3
over 2. now you might have that
memorized say oh i immediately know that
sine of x or sine of theta is square
root of 3 over 2 and you'd be done but i
don't have that memorized or
so let me just draw my unit circle and
when i'm dealing with arcsin i just have
to draw
the first and fourth quadrants of my
unit circle that's the y-axis that's my
x-axis x and y
and where am i
if the sine of something is minus square
root of three over two that means the y
coordinate on the unit circle is minus
square root of three over two so it
means we're right about
it means we are right about there
so this is minus square root of three
over two this is where we are
now what angle gives me that
what angle gives me that let's think
about it a little bit
my my y coordinate is minus square root
of three over two
this is the angle
it's going to be a negative angle
because we're going we're going below
the x-axis in the clockwise direction
and to figure out let me just draw a
little
triangle here let me pick a better color
than that so that's the triangle
let me
do it in
this blue color so let me zoom up that
triangle
like that this is theta
that's theta and what's this length
right here well that's the same as the y
height i guess we could call it which is
square root of 3 over 2. it's minus
because we're going down but let's just
figure out this angle and we know it's
we know it's a negative angle so when
you see square root of three over two
hopefully you recognize hey this is a
30-60-90 triangle the square root of
three over two this side is
one-half and then of course this side is
one because this is a unit circle so its
radius is one so in a 30-60-90 triangle
the side opposite to the square root of
3 over 2 is 60 degrees the side over
here is 30 degrees so we know that our
theta is this is 60 degrees that's its
magnitude but it's going downward so
it's minus 60 degrees so theta is equal
to minus
60 degrees but if we're dealing in
radians that's not good enough so we can
multiply that times
100 sorry
pi
radians for every 180 degrees degrees
cancel out and we're left with theta is
equal to minus pi over 3
radians
and so we can say
we can now make the statements
that
the arc sine
the arc sine of minus square root of 3
over 2 is equal to minus pi over 3
radians
or we could say the inverse sine of
minus square root of 3 over 2 is equal
to
minus pi over 3 radians and to confirm
this let's just
let me get a little calculator out i put
this in radian mode already you can just
check that per second mode i'm in radian
mode
so i know i'm going to get hopefully the
right answer and i want to figure out
the inverse sine so the inverse sine the
second and the sine button
of
the minus
square root of 3
over 2.
it equals see minus 1.04
so it's telling me that this is equal to
this is equal to minus
1.04
radians so my pi over 3 must be equal to
1.04 let's let's see if i can confirm
that so if i were to write minus
minus pi
divided by 3
what do i get i get the exact same value
so my calculator gave me the exact same
value but it might have not been that
helpful because my calculator doesn't
tell me that this is minus pi over 3.